[Music]
with tory poll numbers collapsing number
10 has a grand plan to win voters back
and they're calling it operation red
meat unveiling policies like freezing
the bbc license fee to try to get their
supporters back on side in this week's
magazine douglas murray says he's not
being fooled after 11 years of
conservative rule there's little to show
for it to discuss he joins me on the
show now
douglas as always thank you for joining
spectator tv you write in the magazine
this week about operation red meat boris
johnson's plan to save his premiership
tell us what you make of it
yes operation red meat is the report
that the prime minister is going to try
to overcome
the travails that he has gone through in
recent weeks
by throwing his
voter base some red meat
some
tough tory policies
that will hopefully dampen any
leadership questions around him dampen
uh all of the discontent and remind the
great uh conservative voter base of why
they need boris johnson more than ever
um
i've been looking at a lot of these
policies and they're around immigration
the bbc as you say real red meat for the
base
do you think it's working or do you
think he's just reminding his core base
of what he hasn't done for two and a
half years yeah that's a very important
point exactly as i say in the column my
own view is that there's no reason why
if you haven't done something from day
one you're suddenly going to start doing
it in year three
and i think the conservative voters now
as with previous conservative
governments a right to be skeptical
about this um
as you said there's the bbc what does it
consist of so far nadine dory is
announcing this week there will be a
freeze on the license fee
do you remember the beginning of this
government we had talk of charles moore
no less our own colleague
taking over as chairman of the bbc
they didn't manage with that they didn't
manage anything comparable uh and we've
got this i wouldn't call it red meat i'd
call it rather plain fair uh of saying
that we will have a freeze in the
license fee um i'm not i'm not sure by
the way the bbc is a particularly good
one to run on on that actually the bbc
has um unlike saying american media has
has has a lot of discontents from both
political sides but has still got a
significant amount of trust in the
country including among some or many
conservative voters so i'm not sure
that's the best one to go on but yes
other red meat issues include of course
immigration boris johnson's now going to
have to pretend that he's going to do
something about an issue he hasn't done
anything about for the last two years or
more um he's going to have to talk tough
on an issue which he'd hoped clearly as
i said in the magazine once before he'd
hoped would sort of slide by beneath the
radar boris johnson's hope was that
hundreds and in the end more than a
thousand people coming illegally across
the channel every day
uh was just not going to be of
significant enough interest to detain
the attentions of the british people he
was wrong on that uh but he still hasn't
developed policy but we already see this
week again a little bit of operation red
meat perhaps uh talk of sending in uh
the military to deal with the situation
in the channel uh sending in the royal
navy the army perhaps the raf in due
course
i can't help smiling about this of
course because it's so incredibly
transparent uh it's a sort of tough talk
that some conservatives like to engage
in in the hope that it'll almost
sexually thrill their voters
and of course actually
it doesn't i think the conservative
voters are not uh what boris johnson
thinks they are i think they are as i
think he's making the same mistakes
they're saying the column that theresa
may made
which is when she got that rather
disconcerting sense of disconnect from
the voter base suddenly makes a
presumption that the conservative voter
base is both ugly and stupid yeah and i
think they're neither um but boris
johnson is going the same route it's a
great mistake
you haven't always had such criticism
for the prime minister you once wrote
that he was the only politician of his
generation who could make people feel
good what do you think's changed
yeah i i stick by that i i've always
maintained that
that he has qualities that almost
unheard of in his generation certainly
unparalleled in his generation
uh it used to be the case again you
might say the referendum took some of
this out of out of it but
it used to be the case that if you
mentioned boris's name in the country
first of all first name terms like kylie
like madonna like other sort of
celebrities uh boris always if you say
boris his name to people says oh boris
there was a sort of um lifting of the
spirits a sense of holiday as i've said
before nobody ever said ah teresa
no one ever said ah john good old john
major um it never happened the point is
is that boris had an unusual quality in
politics
but as i mentioned in this week's column
that seems to have faded i'm reminded of
the case of michael barrymore after the
body was found in his pool it wasn't
that michael barrymore's talent
disappeared it wasn't that we didn't
still remember that he was a man capable
of making us laugh it's just that the
laughter died
and something similar has happened in
recent weeks and days with boris johnson
it's the period in which the laughter
has died
we know that he was once able to
entertain
but the question remains over whether he
can govern
and some people would say that the
answer to that question is now in
well i'm curious as to what you would
say douglas i think it's quite clear
that you are disappointed with where his
premiership has taken the country so far
i think it's a damning but very
revealing point that you make that the
laughter has died and and once the
laughter dies you know that's when you
know things are really very grim
do you think it's time that he threw in
the towel
well um it's very interesting watching
the uh stunt which is the best way to
put it on what david davis did at prime
minister's questions this week a very
striking thing to do uh of actually
calling for the prime minister's
resignation in the house of commons on
his own benches
uh some people would say well that's
david davis being david davis um however
it's it's a serious uh
advance really in the movement of
dissatisfaction within the conservative
party
here's the thing that will keep keep
boris johnson in place for the time
being it simply isn't clear that there
is any obvious success and now members
of the conservative party and others who
i speak to say to me well douglas it was
the same before nobody ever arrived in
office fully formed you know even even
the greats like margaret thatcher didn't
arrive into office fully formed as
margaret thatcher so you always take a
bit of a risk on it as it were with a
leader here's the problem though
it's very hard to see
how the conservatives could first of all
engage in a leadership battle at this
stage if they're going to do it they'll
they should do it soon by the way i mean
there's no point in doing this say a
year before the election
um so the first but the first thing is
that in any case
is the country really
up for another conservative party
leadership contest you know there is
this pretence that the conservative
party is this brutally efficient machine
but anyone who's seen it up close knows
that it's much more like a sausage
making factory you really don't want to
see how it works up close the second
thing is of course
is there a successor and i would say at
the moment that the answer to that is
very clearly no
there is no obvious successor to boris
johnson
there are many impressive people around
him and indeed on his benches i would
say the conservative party has
a significant amount of talent including
talent from recent intakes uh it's a
very striking contrast with the labour
party where effectively if you go below
the level of kierstama you get to just
um
an extraordinary array of people some of
whom you can't believe are allowed out
in public let alone loan into the house
of commons
so but it's a different level of talent
on the conservative benches they have
got very significant um talented figures
however are any of them yet in a
position first of all to take over the
reigns of the most important office in
the land and secondly to either keep or
grow that important electoral advance
that boris johnson did make in 2019
it could can anyone honestly say that
rishi sunak for instance um is going to
satisfy uh crucial voters in the red
wall i i'm not sure about that um are
any of the other contenders none of them
spring to mind so i think for the time
being it's likely that johnson will hold
on simply because it's not clear what
the alternative is there is no king or
queen over the water there is no person
absolutely ready to step forward but
as i say that doesn't rule out the
possibility that that there might be a
challenge because of course never forget
that there's an important rule in
politics which is only one thing
unites every single member of the house
of commons and that is the belief
misguided though it almost always is but
at some point history will call and it
will be them
douglas while i have you here let me ask
you one more question going past boris
johnson and his two and a half years in
office and looking more generally at the
conservative party what do you make of
their now 11 years in power
somehow they've had control that long
and yet we've ended up with the biggest
tax burden in 71 years
yes
there's really only one selling point
that conservatives have after 11 years
of conservative majority government and
that is this
they haven't been labor
and that's it
that's almost the sum total of their
abilities and their boasts to date
now of course we had the five years of
the coalition government and david
cameron could always say well we have
this ball and chain around our ankles
called the liberal democrat party
specifically nick clegg that is a
significant ball and chain to have to
suffer along with as you shuffle through
the business of government but then
there was a period in which david
cameron did have a majority there was a
period where theresa may had a majority
she of course blew a majority but we
still had a conservative majority
government we now have a situation with
boris johnson for as i say over two
years where we have not just an atc tory
majority but also a crisis that he could
have used and at the end of that crisis
and that 80-seat majority as i say in
the column and as you well know
the question is
have we been governed by conservatives
and the answer really is no
we've been governed by not labor we've
been governed by not corbyn
we have historic levels of public
borrowing we have tax rises
national insurance rises with the old
trick the old gordon brown trick of
pretending that the national insurance
rise isn't really a tax rise all of the
things we've seen many times before and
what is the one flagship policy of this
government
cop 26
the promise that if we try hard enough
we won't have any electricity by the end
of the decade uh the promise that our
our electricity bills our fuel bills are
all going to keep rising all to get to
an uns uh unsustainable impossible goal
but so the one thing that we have really
got in policy terms from boris johnson
in his prime ministership so far is
greenery uh a sort of particularly in my
form ridiculous form of greenery as i
say in my column this week we voted
conservative as a country in 2019 and we
got the member for brighton pavilion
that is of course caroline lucas
um so
that's the the problem
the conservative voter base will feel as
they often do completely let down by a
conservative government conservative
governments are masters at letting down
their own publics their own voters but
as i say we'll end up always with this
question who else and i would expect by
the way as i mentioned in the column
that operation red meat will also
include a significant dollop of
you thought jeremy corbyn was bad wait
till you see what comrade kirstar would
do if he was in office i'm not sure that
that's a threat that the natural voter
base of the conservative party let alone
the wider country is going to be all
that terrified about in due course
well there you have it viewers douglas
murray's take on the not labour party
douglas as always thanks for joining us
[Music]
you